in other news this morning an airport
wide power outage caused chaos at one of
the nation's busiest airports last night
Airport is losing power Reagan National
Airport outside Washington lost
electricity for about 90 minutes dozens
of flights were delayed and passengers
were stranded on the tarmac Kris Van
Cleave is at the airport at Arlington
Virginia Chris the lights are back on
this morning good morning the lights are
back on this outage hit a little before
10 o'clock last night when both of the
power feeds that come into Reagan
National stopped receiving power from
utility dominion Virginia frightened
passengers posted pictures and video to
social media of the near blackout
conditions in the terminals TSA
checkpoints briefly lost power but
passengers were eventually screened
during the outage flights were held for
a time without the use of electric jet
bridges passengers were stuck on the
tarmac waiting to deplane in some cases
for over an hour they had to use air
stairs generators provided emergency
lighting to parts of the terminal in
critical operating systems like the
control tower and runway lights
firefighters were called when a
generator started to smoke but no fire
was found fortunately this happened at
basically the slowest time at Reagan
National Airport still two American
flights were canceled for Southwest
flights diverted to nearby BWI dominion
Virginia tells CBS News they're still
investigating why the lights went out
they're back on and flights are
operating normally today all right
that's good news thank you Chris